how are you getting asked you all don't
worry she's a good health it was really
beautiful to feel this sort of marvel
sisterhood you know and we're all coming
from so many different films that we all
came together it's kind of like I see
what you do I know your powers okay show
me what you got and then we just clicked
and we would just like to chair and each
other on everyone's just kind of taking
their turns moving around trying to help
each other out is so fun you sure that
day was in seen we were all in it
together and it felt electric it was
really really cool
[Music]
you know I normally don't watch a play
back on the monitor but I wanted to see
that reveal of all the women of Marvel
and I thought it was really powerful and
really exhilarating and I was thinking
of all of the young girls in the
audience who will probably feel really
inspired by that in one way or another
so it was a really nice thing to be a
part of this is the fight of our lives
we are getting the whole team right oh
it's up regular-sized man hey guys let's
do it
is that everyone you wanted more
are you crying this is my destiny
Avengers Assemble
[Applause]
[Music]
no no give me that you have the little
one
[Music]
[Music]